come dignified resilient these are the
scenes organizers had called for but few
expected it to look quite like this
protesters of all ages braving the
pouring rain to march the crowd swelling
in every direction bringing parts of the
city to a total standstill this see
protesters marching through the streets
feels like it's never going to end a lot
of these protesters will have faith tear
gas rubber bullets over the last few
weeks
this torrential rain is certainly not
going to faze them these demonstrators
had a point to prove
many had felt weeks of clashes and
shocking scenes at Hong Kong Airport on
Tuesday had tarnished their movement
Beijing branding the more violent
protesters close to terrorists but as
they arrived on Sunday they were united
people power and peace their weapons of
choice in the battle for their image
last week there's a lot of protests in
Airport and I think that's caught a lot
of attention for the whole world that's
why I think today is one of the
important day for us to see peaceful and
try to be a rational and civilized group
of people because I know the worst
washing us as night fell the true test
began as protesters converged outside
the government complex it seemed like
this could end like so many protests
before tear gas masks at the ready
trepidation police could come in at any
moment to disperse the crowd then came
this small clusters of protesters
spreading through the crowd mission
complete they chant everyone go home
we have a victory today we have nearly
two million people coming out to voice
out our five demands peacefully so we
won today's protest to be absolutely
peaceful and then so that's why we are
encouraging people to go home
11 weeks into this movement they've
proven they still enjoy broad support as
more people take up the cry the
demonstrators dispersed no need for riot
police to move in these protesters were
policing themselves for the first
weekend in weeks
tear gas masks unused